my name is mark tyrell i am the uh
host
moderator for pi data global for this
session
uh i'd like to introduce you to jacob
tomlinson
we'll be conducting the session or the
the workshop today
on gpu development within python 101
uh jacob is a senior python software
engineer at nvidia
and i'm sure you can pick it up from
there jacob and probably introduce
yourself better than i can so i'll hand
it over to you now
sure thanks mark uh yeah hi everybody
i'm jacob i'm a software engineer at
nvidia
i mainly work on a suite of open source
python libraries called rapids which are
like gpu accelerated
uh kind of re-implementations of the
core pi data stack so numpy pandas
psychic learn you're kind of
re-implemented as
like coupey qdf uh qml and a whole bunch
of other tools within that suite right
so i work a bunch on that i'm also a
dust maintainer that's kind of like my
main contribution to rapids actually
because we use dusk within rapids to
scale out to multi-gpu workloads so i do
a bunch of work on das
kind of day-to-day
but the idea of this workshop really is
um i joined nvidia like two years ago i
was already a das maintainer i was
already working in the like python pi
data space
um
and i kind of came into nvidia fresh not
really knowing a huge amount about gpus
i knew about distributed computing and
that was kind of what i was bringing to
the
to the table so in the last couple of
years that i've been in the organization
i've been slowly kind of skilling up on
gpu development and so it's not like a
huge
part of my workload really i'm more
focused on the distributed side of
things but um as i've kind of gained
knowledge of of how to write gpu code
and how to interact with gpus i wanted
to put together a tutorial that's maybe
like uh like an insider novices
perspective right i work at nvidia but
i'm not like a full-on gpu developer um
so maybe i can kind of share what i've
learned and give you hopefully like a
gentle introduction to gpu development
in python
so
uh let me share my screen and we're
gonna work through
a bunch of material basically uh on
on binder but on like a specific binder
that i've set up so if i jump over to
here
um
you should be able to see that i'm
already logged in if you can't see what
i'm doing please shout or i'll prove the
host but um
if you uh i've got a bitly url down in
the bottom corner so this isn't regular
binder this is a binder that i've thrown
up for this session
um
so this bitly url down here which should
take you to this binder page now this is
like a binder is great it's open source
uh you know free
platform for running sets of notebooks
in like an interactive environment but
the default binder environment doesn't
have any gpus and since we're going to
be doing some gpu development um we need
some gpus so i've thrown up my own stack
of binder it's just running on some
random like google cloud machines at the
moment now you should be able to come
through uh that link should kind of
populate you through all the way through
to this page but um the the actual
material is on on my github so uh if you
head to github it's just under jacob
thomas
gpu python tutorial this is the material
we're going to be going to be running
through today um
so kind of if you can all start going
and getting through to this point it
might take a little while to get in i've
tried to like preheat the cluster i
think there's there's like a thousand uh
there's about a hundred seats uh
available so as long as we don't go over
maybe a hundred participants in this
tutorial we should be fine
if you have any trouble with this kind
of shout in the chat i can uh kind of
point you to other places but really uh
this is gonna be the best way to run
through this material uh every
participant when you come through and
into the structure environment you'll
get a dedicated uh p100 instance
um
uh p100 gpu sorry that you can
you can make use of so let me kind of
ramble my way through the the intro and
hopefully you'll kind of get yourself
set up to to this point don't worry too
much about the the things i've got down
there the side here we'll kind of get to
all of that later
but yeah as i said i've kind of been
learning this
you know gpu development over the last
couple of years and
i think the most surprising thing to me
is i didn't have to learn any c plus
plus i'm not really you know the only c
plus plus i ever really write is like
arduino microcontroller stuff in my free
time um i don't really have to write c
plus plus as part of my work um and i
haven't had to write any c plus plus as
part of this tutorial everything here is
in pure python using some like fantastic
open source libraries that we already
have within our community
so we're going to work through like a
bunch of notebooks if i just pop open
the file browser uh i'll keep that
closed to try and keep the clutter off
but you can see we've got a whole bunch
of things that we're going to run
through uh here
let me drag that over there
we're mostly going to focus on number
for the first half of this and we'll get
into what number is in a minute but
we're going to kind of go through
gpu
what the programming model is like it's
like a completely different paradigm to
writing for the cpu
um we're going to start writing a bit of
like hello world code and digging a
little bit into how we manage memory and
how things are shared between the cpu
and gpu
then once we've gone through all of that
which is like you know reasonably intro
hello world type stuff we'll dig a bit
into figuring out what's going on in the
gpu we'll have a look at um
and then we'll look at some some more
higher abstracted libraries so have a
look at coupe i will have a look at um
qdf which is like a dataframe library
we'll have a little look at qml at the
end which is like a machine learning
library we'll do a little bit of like
we'll train a model and do a little bit
of machine learning at the end time
permitting uh this i've run this before
it took kind of just over the the 90
minutes so i'm going to try and keep
keep the time and we should be able to
get through all this material um a
couple of these notebooks are labs so
i'll be quiet for five or ten minutes
let you have a work through those um as
we go i think there's a couple of them
in there
uh and then we'll go through the answers
of those together to try and give you an
opportunity to to explore that
so
let's kind of jump straight into this
this first notebook and figure out where
we're going i'm just gonna i just
cleared all my um
kernels let me just shut them all down
again played all my notebook outputs to
neaten this up but let's jump into here
and then i'm just going to make sure
i've got a kernel on this one i don't
know if i need it but anyway
so
cpus and gpus are
two different types of processor that
you have in your computer right and it's
you know i've always thought of you know
your cpu is the brain of your machine
and it is handling everything that's
going on and traditionally the gpu is
there for doing graphics acceleration
right it's there to calculate what
pixels should be rendered onto the
screen primarily in video games but also
used a bunch of movies and
you know video editing and photography
and all that kind of stuff
now over the last i don't know 10 years
or so
gpus are becoming more and more general
purpose in their in their use and you
can run kind of any code now on that
that processor
and that processor is architected in a
completely different way to a cpu so if
you look at this big diagram here that i
grabbed off the nvidia documentation
site
you can see the cpu on the left has
generally got a small number of cores
right this is showing a four core
processor uh you know modern processors
maybe go up to
eight cores that you might find in like
a laptop sometimes those cores can be
shared between two different threads so
you get hyper threading and it kind of
shows more
in high-end servers you may get more
threads than that um and calls but you
tend to have like a small number of very
powerful cores that are all kind of
controlled independently the machine can
be running different things together but
you know say you've got a four core
processor you can run four processors
at a time on that on that
chip and the operating system will be
handling sharing those calls between all
the applications running on your machine
you've got like a whole bunch of caches
and then you have some ram in your
machine and that is like your main
memory your applications your data gets
loaded into that that ram
now gpu's different in that it's got
many many many calls uh i can't remember
off the top my head for the p100s we've
got here but it's going to be you know a
few thousand cores
um in in the gpu and all of these calls
have have a lot more like shared
resources so they have shared uh control
registers they have uh shared caches
they have shared ram they have smaller
amounts of cash
and that's because we work with all of
these cores as if they're one
thing so
although we have you know maybe a
thousand cores in our gpu we're still
going to pass a function to it and that
same function is just going to get
called on all of the cores in uh in
parallel and so you have to think about
writing your code in a way that what
happens if i execute this many many
times at the same time
compared to
you know traditional processing where
you might think about well i've got a
single threaded application i might fork
my process and i'd do a couple of things
on a couple of different threads um if
you're if you're kind of getting fancy
with it but uh the gpu is a completely
different paradigm
so there's there's a great video um from
mythbusters that you can find on their
video youtube channel i recommend you
you go and watch that i'm what i'm going
to do is i'm going to press play but uh
you won't be able to hear it but i'll
just kind of talk you through what
they're saying in the video here right
so the first thing they've got is
they've got this little robot that is a
is a cpu and it's going to paint a
picture using paintballs and so it is
going to fire one paintball at a time
and it's going to paint a picture on a
piece of paper this is kind of what a
cpu is doing right it's doing one
operation at a time it's doing it pretty
quickly
and it's pretty versatile right but you
can get it to
do all the things you want you can take
that paintball gun off and put something
else on the end of it and now it's kind
of a more robust machine
whereas the gpu is kind of more
custom designed for doing one thing and
doing it well and so they've got their
second machine here which has got you
know thousands of paintball tubes in
there
and they're all preloaded with a
paintball and they're all connected to
these big gas canisters and when they
set this machine off it's going to go
off and all of those tubes are going to
shoot paintballs out all at the same
time they're doing exactly the same
thing but they've got a different
configuration right they've each got a
different color in and so they just
paint this picture in one big go
and so this is more akin to what a gpu
is doing right it's doing the same
operation with slight modifications
in one go and so you can kind of batch
through your work
um now apologies if that video didn't
come across in the screen share so well
but please do you know click the link
watch the video is really good
so
thinking about the fact that we've got
these two separate devices whenever we
write python code traditionally it's
going to run on the cpu right i can open
up a text editor so i can
you know
write print hello world
and i can run that python script i can
just write python myscript
and it will run and i will know that
that will run on the cpu
and so
how do we run something on the gpu we
have to specifically
ask
the cpu to tell the gpu to do something
it's you know it's like a
secondary device that we have to
explicitly interact with and a great way
i found to think about this for myself
is that think about trying to run code
on a different machine right instead of
running this python script on my laptop
what if i want to run this python script
on a server that i've got or some you
know machine in the cloud or a super
computer or something right well the
first thing i'm going to have to do is
i'm going to have to connect to that
other machine i'm going to have to log
into that other machine somehow maybe
i'd use ssh maybe i'm going to use you
know vnc or remote desktop to get like a
graphical uh view into that machine but
i'm going to need to connect to that
machine login
and then i'm going to need to copy my
script onto that machine and so i might
use scp you might use ftp there's like a
you know myriad of different ways that
you can copy a file from one machine to
another but i'm i'm going to have to
copy my code from my laptop onto the
server
and then over my remote connection i'm
going to have to ask it to execute that
script and i'm going to write you know
python my script but in like a bash
prompt from that machine and so
it's kind of you know running stuff on a
gpu is is a similar thing
in that it's like a separate device and
you've got to think of it as a separate
device
but instead of using ssh or remote
desktop or anything like that we're
going to use something called cuda right
this is uh you know nvidia's
way of interacting with nvidia gpus
and it's got all the same kind of
utilities right you've got functions
that you can call for connecting to the
device you've got functions you can call
to move uh code onto the device your
functions you can call to move memory
back and forth and data around and then
you've got functions that you can call
that will execute those functions
on the gpu and so um
you know
cuda allows us to
interact with the gpu in the same way
you would interact with a separate
machine
now cuda historically has been
written in c plus plus it's a language
extension to c plus plus
um but at the beginning of this i said
we're not going to see any c plus and
don't worry we're not going to dig into
any c plus plus um cuda's kind of been
growing recently there is actually kind
of native support in python coming but
the main way that we tend to interact
with cuda through python at the moment
is with a library called number
our number is a really awesome library
just for for speeding up your python
code and if you've not seen it before i
recommend you go and check it out
um through this tutorial we're going to
be using the cuda sub package of number
but what number does is it looks at your
code
and you can use like a decorator in
number
to decorate a function and when you call
that function number will inspect the
code it will use llvm to kind of tr
compile that python into something
that's a lower level so this is you know
it's a different way of executing python
code
number supports like a subset of the
python language
and this works on cpus really well right
you can decorate functions with with
number jit and it will compile that
function at runtime and execute it and
you get some performance boost
but number has also got a cuda extension
which means that you you write a
function in python you decorate it with
the number cuda
decorator
and it will compile it using the the
nvidia compiler into something that is
like a
cuda compatible binary and it also
handles binding to cuda to actually
execute that function
now that's kind of gone a little deeper
in the explanation than we're really
going to need to worry about as we go
through
but just you know suffice to say we're
going to be using number to run our
python code on our gpu
now we're going to dig into this low
level for a little while but then
towards the end of the tutorial we're
going to come up some higher level
libraries where we don't have to worry
so much about code getting compiled
across and moved around um and we can
interact with arrays and data frames and
things in a way that maybe feels
familiar if you if you've used numpy or
pandas um and those are through the the
rapids libraries so coupon pdf qml etc
um we'll kind of touch on that a little
bit more towards the end
so let me uh move on to the next
notebook i'm just going to stop the kind
of one on that one just to keep my
session as clean as i can
so
number this first
notebook i'm going to dig into
what the execution model is like on a
gpu uh with number
so
yeah
just trying to think about what i've
what i've gone through and what i've not
gone through
so
number handles converting your code and
moving your memory back and forth
and so the first thing we need to worry
about is writing some code to run on the
gpu
when we talk about code that's going to
run on the gpu we talk about things
called kernels now this isn't the same
as like the linux kernel or anything
like that a kernel is like a piece of
code a piece of compiled code that is
going to execute on the gpu
but you know that's a slightly scary
word and it's an unusual word so let's
just think of it as a function kernels
are just functions but they have two um
very different uh features that make
them slightly different from a function
so the first thing is that a kernel
can't return we can't return anything
from our function and that's because
we're going to call this kernel
thousands of times on our gpu we don't
want every single one of those trying to
return something and shove data back
somewhere to the cpu to some other
thread but returns don't make so much
sense so what we do
when we're writing for the gpu is we
just modify memory right we move some
some data into memory sometimes that's
just like a big empty block of space
that we're going to write to
um and then as we run our
kernels well you know our kernel is run
many times each one of those executions
of this this function is going to modify
some piece of memory
and then once they've all finished we
can go and retrieve that memory and grab
our result
so
in addition to not being able to return
and having to modify memory um the other
thing we have to do is we have to
specify something called the thread
hierarchy and this is the
this kind of size and shape of the
execution of this function and this is
like a slightly abstract thing and it's
a bit weird to think about when you
first start thinking about it this is
one of the big hurdles i had to jump
over mentally when i was getting into
gpu development but you basically have
to say you know i have this function i
want it to be called 12 000 times on the
gpu
and you know you have to make that
decision how many times will this be
called um
and that
kind of the number of times it's going
to be called depends on your code
depends on what you're writing quite
often this kind of stuff is used for
image processing and we're going to do
some image processing uh a bit later in
this tutorial so
say i have an image that's like 100 by
100 pixels that means i need to if i
want to do some operation on that image
and modify each pixel i need my my
function my kernel to be run a hundred
by a hundred times right ten thousand
times so i can kind of work out based on
my problem how many times i'm gonna need
to execute this
but we can't just say please run my
function a hundred thousand times ten
thousand times um we have to specify it
in in a way that the gpu is expecting
and this is because gpus do have a
finite number of calls so you can't just
say do it you know two million times and
be able to do that all at the same time
because there might be only a thousand
processing calls in there so it's going
to need to batch those executions you
can say to it call it two million times
but it'll do it in in chunks
and we tend to call those chunks
blocks so
what we do is we specify
how many threads we want in each block
and then how many blocks we want in each
grid when we call a function we call it
a grid um so
we kind of got some diagrams here that
i've again pulled from the mvd
documentation and you can see
each block here at the bottom of this
diagram i don't know if you can see my
pointer but the the kind of or the
yellowy box with the orange box is in
this is a block which contains threads
and you have to specify how many threads
go in your block this is kind of the
smallest unit of measure that we can
work with
now there are some advantages uh to
having threads in the same block they've
got like different levels of cash that
they can access and this does matter
when you really get into the weeds but
i'm not going to worry too much about
that let's just think of this as we need
to specify how many threads are in a
block
and then we need to specify how many
blocks we want to call all together so
say we set our blocks uh the number of
threads to 512 and just because that's a
nice round binary number um and say we
want to call our function 10 000 times
we need to work out well we're going to
do it in blocks of 512 so how many of
those blocks do i need to cover you know
the number of times i want to call this
so once we've kind of decided how we're
going to chunk up our executions
those blocks get passed to the gpu and
the gpu will hand those to
kind of the smaller units of compute on
the gpu which are called streaming
multiprocessors but that let's not worry
too deeply about that
um all that we need to take away from
here really is that we're going to write
some functions those functions are going
to modify memory instead of returning
and we need to tell it how many times to
run those
now we have some rules of thumb for
working out some of this some of these
numbers because we're going to have to
work these out
the the number of threads per block
should be around multiple of 32 this is
just because gpus have
um some kind of small unit of measure
called a warp which again don't worry
too much but we just tend to say rule of
thumb
um
don't make them odd numbers
you know they need to be multiple of 32.
a good place to start generally is like
128 256 512 maybe 1024 if you've got
like a modern gpu
um
and so
we're just kind of
go with these defaults these defaults
are written in the number documentation
they're written in their nvidia
documentation let's just assume they're
good and carry on
so um
what i'm going to do quickly i'm just
going to pause for a second and have a
look at
my kubernetes cluster and make sure
folks are managing to
kind of log in and get set up on binder
i don't know if you can see my screen
but it doesn't matter too much but yes
okay it looks like a bunch of people are
logged in
um
it looks like a whole bunch of folks
who've got pending
containers
nothing's running yet so
what i might do
looks like my placeholders are not being
shifted out uh in the chat can anybody
shout if they've managed to get the the
notebooks open
to this point where you can kind of see
what we're running through here
uh if you
okay somebody said uh it's still
spinning with an empty
build log okay that's fine let me just
uh
change one little number here
so what i did is i pre-scaled my cluster
with a bunch of placeholder containers
um
though you should disrupt as you log in
you it should launch a container for you
and that pushes out one of my like low
priority containers that i
put on to kind of save seats for
everybody um
but
that didn't seem to have worked so let
me just make sure
that's happened okay lots of folks are
now in like a running state
um
few pokes uh saying
okay work this time yeah so that seems
to clear things up there's this bitly
link down in the bottom here of my
screen share um please head there if you
haven't uh been able to get there yet um
it should take you through to this
notebook environment the cluster may
start trying to scale down now to
numbers that we're at but um
we'll see
it's like getting a little want opening
the door so
uh
let me just keep an eye on the chat
how's everybody doing
okay folks are managing to get in that's
awesome
so once you're in you know head to
notebook number two um and we'll carry
on chugging through this together
so
let's actually write some code let's dig
in some code we've got i've been talking
at you for 20 minutes already
let's actually look at some
interesting stuff so
let's start with a really minimal
problem and we'll start to like smoosh
it into a way that can run on the gpu so
we'll start with a little bit of cpu
code and then we'll kind of squeeze it
over onto the gpu
so we have to start thinking about our
code in
executing it in like a vectorized way
which if you've worked with numpy uh you
probably feel familiar with if you work
pandas that should feel familiar um if
you've done anything with like a list
comprehension um that is starting to
feel a bit more kind of vectory so
if we have a look at
this little piece of code here if i have
um
all the numbers from not to 10
and i have a little function called foo
that just returns each one doesn't do
anything to it yet it just returns that
if i want to run foo on each of those
numbers in my range i can do a list
comprehension that looks like this i can
say foo i for i in data
if i run this cell
it gives me a list with my numbers in
which is kind of what i would expect it
to do it's it's iterating through all of
those things but this is you know this
list comprehension is like a single call
i've said here's a list of of
data and here's a function please apply
that function to my list of data
and you know i could write this as a for
loop but
writing it in a list comprehension like
this on one line
is the right kind of mindset that we
want for executing stuff on the gpu
so let's kind of move on and try and
move this function in a direction that
we can actually execute it on the gpu
so
we've returned stuff that's uh already a
big no no right we can't return stuff
from our kernels running on the gpu
so let's change the cell around a bit
and we're going to say let's generate
our numbers again not to 10 but instead
of
returning we're going to have another
array and we're going to append our
numbers to that array
so we're going to have this this empty
output array here and when we call
through on our our number um we're just
going to append that to the list
and then if we do our kind of
parallel execution here with our list
comprehension um these numbers will get
added to that appended to that output
and if we have a look at the output
should look exactly the same right it's
done
done kind of what we want so our
function now doesn't return which is
great
but there's a few other kind of little
little things we need to consider about
our gpu so we can't actually have uh
zero length arrays like this and then
add new elements to them on the gpu
sadly we have to think about things in
like a slightly more limited uh way
sometimes writing code for the gpu you
feel a little bit like you've got one
arm tight behind your back um because
there are just a few things that are
that are missing um because it's kind of
uh uh
the compute environment is slightly less
mature than the cpu environment there's
fewer kind of um pleasantries about it
so one of the things is
this output array needs to already be
the length that we expect it to be and
we're going to update elements in it
instead of adding new elements we just
say well um our output is going to be 10
long and we know that up front right
we've got 10 numbers in our data
so our output is going to be 10 numbers
long
so we need to kind of
pre-initialize some array with 10
elements and then our function is just
going to go up and modify
um an element within that array
so we'll use numpy just to simplify
creating these arrays
um here and also because numpy plays
nicely with a number
so
what we'll do is instead of doing our
range we're going to call uh
numpy dot as array on our range and
that's just because um
it'll be more useful when we do things
in in on the gpu in a minute having it
as a numpy array as opposed to like a
native python
list that is actually a
a generator here an iterator so um
anyway in this example we're now moving
to numpy arrays if you've not used numpy
kind of don't be too frightened at this
point numpy arrays are you know a bit
like lists but they can have multiple
dimensions there's a slightly lower
level thing they're they're implemented
on the back end in c and they're they're
very fast and a nice way of working with
arrays of data so first thing we're
going to create here is this 10 long
array that's full of our numbers all
through 9. now we're going to create an
output array so this is just going to be
we're going to use mp.0s which is going
to make us an empty array basically it's
just going to be full of zeros and we're
going to specify it should be the same
length as our data so we make our data
and then we make it like an output
that's the same shape and size basically
which is you know one by ten if you
imagine as like a two-dimensional object
then we're going to modify our foo
function again so instead of appending
we're gonna
update an index but
we're going to update that index
relative to the number that we get and
that that makes sense in this context
because we we've got the unique numbers
from naught through nine
so we can access our array through the
index is not through nine
and we'll update the output array at
those indexes
um
what we'll have to worry about in the
future is
our input data won't be like this so
we'll have to worry about how to to get
these indexes but it turns out that's
nice and easy on on the gpu with with
number so
we will go through this output array
at each index and we'll just set that
index equal to i so if i do this again
with my actual list comprehension uh oh
i haven't imported the numpy i forgot
that cell
um now we can see our output array this
looks slightly different because this is
what numpy gives us as a wrapper but um
we can see it's an array of numbers from
naught through nine
uh it's just shown as the decimal point
even though there's no thing it's
converted them all into floats for us
but
it's done exactly the same thing we've
taken an input array we've taken an
output array and we've cooled our
function on each element and put the
output of that function
into our output array so we can work
with it now finally the exciting time is
let's do this but on the gpu
so the first thing we're going to do is
from number import cuda
and we'll do the same with our data
again right we'll have our not through 9
and we'll have our output array of zeros
and our foo looks slightly different
here we're not calling through
and passing it like an element from our
input array what we're doing is we're
calling foo and we're passing it
pointers to both of those arrays the
input and the output so phu is kind of
aware of both the arrays execution time
and this means that every single
invocation of foo
is the same right it's not being passed
different data it's not being handed
anything it's just we're going to say
let's call this however many times we're
going to call it
and
you should just be able to see your data
so
how does our function know
what to operate on right i thought each
function call is only going to operate
on one number so it needs to know
which number do i do i work with
and one of the nice features about cuda
is say we call our function a thousand
times each of those functions can ask
which function am i am i function number
seven are my function number 412
like it can ask through the cuda api who
am i where am i what should i be doing
and it will get back an index so if we
say we want to run it however many times
it can ask which index it is within that
grid
so we can do here this call cuda.grid uh
and we pass it a one here just to say
we're working with one dimensional grids
at the moment we'll get onto fancy
multi-dimensional grids in a bit but we
say we're going to call this function 10
times because we've got 10 numbers in
our array
we're just going to have the numbers not
1 through 10. um
if we're going to call it 100 times we
could either have the numbers
like naught through 10 or we could have
like a 10 by 10 grid of of indexes as
well but we'll come to that we'll come
to that so we can get this this i within
our function so now our function knows
who it is right each one
gets a unique number and it knows it can
then do something different at this
stage
and i think this is one of the things
that like changed my perspective a
little bit on gpu programming is you
know where's the flexibility if every
thread has to do the same thing what you
know what do i do here
it's like well
the invocation is the same they both get
past a pointer to the array
but then
they can ask well who am i and then they
can each thread can do whatever it wants
right i can have if i equals zero do
this if i equals two do this and you
know each thread can kind of go off on
its different little path there and so
actually you've got all of these cores
that you can get to do
all of these different things if you
want to
the only caveat here is when you call
the function
everything blocks until every single
thread is done
and if those threads need to talk to
each other or do anything like that you
increase complexity and if they you know
if one crashes or gets stuck or you know
anything happens if something takes more
time all the rest are just going to wait
for it and so you're going to probably
get
loss of performance if you've just got
one call like hanging around doing
something that all the rest have already
finished so it's best to you know you
can have your each thread do something
slightly different but it's best to have
them doing things that are like roughly
the same so that they take roughly the
same amount of time to execute um
and you know we're talking like
nanosecond level of how long they take
to execute here so
um you just need to kind of keep
everything lined up
but then we're going to do the same
thing we've got our output array here
we've got this pointer that we've passed
in
and we're just going to update this
element we're going to say i which is is
the number that cuda.grid has given us
equals
i um now we could actually
we actually want it to be the input
array i think i've made a mistake there
i need to update that now but we want to
set the output array i to be equal to
the input array i it's just going to
copy one number
and now
we're going to do something that looks a
lot like our list comprehension but this
is us actually invoking our kernel on
the gpu
so we have our function that we've
decorated with cuda.jit this is what
turns it into a kernel this is what
stops it from being a python function
turns it into a cuda kernel is this this
cuda dot jit decorator here
so we call our function kind of directly
as if you would call any other function
but we're doing something slightly
strange here instead of going straight
to round brackets and passing in some
arguments we're giving us some square
brackets first with some numbers in
and this is where we're specifying our
like grid and our grid size right our
thread size and our block size
now
the way that i've set this up just for
this quick little example is we're going
to have one block and that block is
going to be 10 elements long which you
know breaks all the rules that i said
before um we're not really doing much by
calculating here and it's not a multiple
of 32
but we're just going to call this this
function exactly the number of times we
need to call this function
so
the number of times that foo will be
called is these two numbers multiplied
together so 1 times 10. it's going to be
called 10 times
and then we pass it our arguments
through round brackets so this function
call looks slightly unusual but
hopefully makes sense as to what it's
doing it's kind of configuring the
kernel with its number of invocations
and then executing it kind of all in one
go
so we can run this
and
i don't know if you saw what happened
but my little gpu monitoring things on
the side like flickered ever so slightly
and i've got a bit of memory usage now
that's mostly like my cuda environment
being been initialized on the gpu but
i've got my array back and this code
here inside the function
executed on my gpu i ran some code i
wrote it in pure python and i ran that
code on on the gpu and it worked
so hooray if you're following along and
you've run that cell congratulations
you've you've run like a very basic
function on a gpu floating out in the
cloud somewhere
so
that's great uh there's a bunch of
explanation here that i've kind of
already gone through over what happened
there but now let's start pushing this a
little bigger because you know we only
ran that function 10 times and we're
meant to do it in multiples of 32 so
we're like way below the smallest size
we really should be running
and gpus are kind of designed to be you
know being having these functions called
hundreds or thousands or millions of
times not 10 times so let's have a look
at maybe a slightly larger
thing that we want to look at
so let's start with a big array let's
have a random numpy array that's got 30
million
random numbers in it
and then let's make an output array
that's got 30 million zeros in it so
we've got a nice big
input we've got a nice big output and
now let's actually do something instead
of just like slotting a number from one
into the other let's do some maths let's
not go crazy but let's do some math so
what we'll do is in our foo function
here
let's do this on the cpu first and see
how long it takes
this looks a bit like the example we
were doing a minute ago we've got a foo
function which takes i
and we're going to update
uh
the output array at i
with the number from the input array at
i
times two we're just going to multiply
all these numbers by two basically
um and we're going to call that in a
list comprehension
um and now we're you know we've kind of
moved our
our range isn't our input data anymore
so we've kind of had to smush that in
here so we're now going to call
uh foo
30 million times and each one of those
invocations is gonna update a single
number in the array it's gonna take a
number from the input it's going to
double it and it's going to put it into
the output and it's just going to do
that sequentially on the cpu in python
in probably the least efficient way i
could think of writing this code
and if we if we run this cell now
one core of my processor is just going
to grab a number doubling it and putting
it into this output array
and it's you know it's not ideal that
took 15 seconds on this cpu
uh i think i wrote 10 in in the notebook
so my local machine must be slightly
faster than whatever this cloud cpu is
but it took 15 seconds to grab each of
those numbers double it and put it into
the output array
now let's do exactly the same thing but
on the gpu
so let's just import math because we're
gonna
do a little bit of math in a second
um
but let's
first off reset our output array so
we're just gonna make our output a bunch
of zeros again so that we don't kind of
cheat and look at the answers
but then we need to decide well how many
times am i going to call this function
we know we want to call it 30 million
times because there's 30 million things
in the array we've kind of decided that
out front that's something we know
but we have to specify this in a thread
size and a block size so let's just
choose a thread size the documentation
said 128 is good so let's go with 128.
so what we need to do now is work out
well
if i'm going to do this in blocks of 128
how many blocks of 128 do i need and
well we can work that out with uh this
little line here that's just gonna you
know
divide the shape by the the size of the
thread and then you know give us the
ceiling of that
so
we're actually going to overshoot
because
three uh 30 million
isn't divisible by 128. so we're going
to call our function slightly more times
um
but those last
threads that have kind of gone off the
end of the array
in this case they're actually going to
going to fail but that error gets
swallowed up but um
in the future we might want to be a bit
more thoughtful about saying well if
you've gone off the edge of the array
you probably shouldn't do anything we'll
throw a little if statement in there but
we'll worry about that later
so we have our kernel again it looks a
bit like our kernel from before we've
coo dot jitted our function and instead
of passing it individual elements we're
passing it the full pointers to the
arrays
they're grabbing their indexes from cuda
grid
and then we're going to update the
output array with the input array times
two
and then we can execute this we can pass
it our block size and our thread size
give it our two arrays and call output
let's see how long this takes
that took 293 milliseconds and again i
don't know if the screen share quite
captured it but my gpu kind of fluffed
it ever so slightly um so that's
insanely faster right the the
gpu
took all of that data it doubled all
those numbers and it handed them back
again
really really fast because it can run so
many of these operations uh in parallel
so that's that's great now
if you've used numpy before you'll
notice that my example here was was mean
right this was
not a fair example this is not how you
would actually do this on a cpu so
comparing what the cpu here is doing
with the gpu is probably not a fair
comparison but i did that on purpose
because
if we have a look at doing this in numpy
which is like a c accelerated cpu way of
doing this it'll use all the calls in
the cpu it'll do the same kind of batch
processing and if i double these numbers
and time it
actually
the cpu wins in this case
so although our gpu is is crazily faster
than doing it in pure python um it's not
as fast as doing this uh
in c
and so
let's dig a little bit into why the gpu
is wasn't faster in this case now
the answer to that is we're paying a
memory transfer penalty
so we have
our arrays of numbers right our random
array and our output array that we've
created with numpy so those two arrays
live on our cpu
but up here
we called this foo
function which is going to run on our
gpu and we passed it these two arrays
and the gpu has a whole separate set of
ram to our cpu so
numbers helping us out here right we've
passed this this kernel two cpu arrays
and number goes oh well the gpu doesn't
have access to those so i'm gonna copy
those arrays onto the gpu i'm gonna call
the function and it's going to work on
them and then you're probably going to
want the answer back in python cpu land
so i'm going to copy these arrays back
again
and that's what's taking the bulk of
this time
is doing this this automatic memory
management
now
if we were doing something more complex
in the function then this memory
transfer is you know going to be the
same penalty each time
it's not going to get it any
uh
longer to transfer that data so if we do
more work on the gpu it becomes like a
smaller and smaller slice at the moment
but right now it's like dwarfing our
calculation and what if we did that and
then called another kernel on our data
and then called another kernel on our
data numbers are going to be very
happily and very nicely copy that data
back and forth for us and we're going to
pay that penalty each time
so although having automatic memory
management makes our life easier in our
little hello world example
we might actually want to
explicitly move our data to the gpu and
explicitly move it back
but we have some functions that can do
that for us so
we can do something
like
call cuda.2device on an array to tell
number please actually copy this array
to the device right now we'll do
something with it later and we get this
new pointer back which is a pointer to
the array on the gpu
and we can do the same with our zeros as
well we'll kind of recreate those as we
as we go here just make sure they are
actually full of zeros so
i've run this cell i've copied my random
array to the gpu i've copied my output
array to the gpu
now if i run
my gpu kernel on that array
it's not going to pay that penalty right
the data's already there it's already
sat on my gpu so if i run this it's just
going to do the doubling now if i run
this now it takes
473 microseconds right which is
way faster than the cpu did it you know
so we've kind of cut down from 15
seconds doing it in like uh you know not
very good pure python way gone down to
you know
uh quarter of a second in a not very
good gpu way
tenth of a second in
a good cpu way
but now we're down to like thousands of
a second in
um
a good gpu way
but the kind of challenge with this is
our data is still on the gpu right it's
still sat there the output array is
still on the gpu we copied it there
it was already there so number's not
going to be helpful and move it back to
us
so we have to explicitly say copy to
host to pull our array back onto our cpu
again
and we can have a look at the output
here so this makes a lot more sense if i
want to
run some code
that's going to uh you know do a few
different kernels because i don't want
to pay that penalty if i do something
like this where i do foo bar and bars on
my data i'm going to pay that penalty
over and over whereas if i copy my data
down call foobar and pass and then copy
my data back it's going to be much more
performant
so that was kind of like an intro to
number and how we can use number cuda to
run on the gpu
next thing uh in this tutorial is uh
number lab so
um i'll go into the chat and like answer
any questions that are going on there um
and yeah so we'll see you back in in
five or ten minutes
so there's a question here what happens
if two threads modify the same location
in the output array
well
you don't know which thread is going to
get called first if they're in the same
block then they might get called at
exactly the same time they might be like
a few microseconds off if they're in
separate blocks it might happen like a
couple of nanoseconds later whoever's
called second is going to win right
there you know one of them is going to
update the output array then the other
one's going to update the output array
and they're just going to kind of
clobber each other and step on each
other's toes so you can do it it's not
it's not going to be the end of the
world but you're you are going to
kind of
corrupt your data as as you're writing
and other questions i didn't understand
how uh we've defined how many times the
function is meant to be called okay so
that's those the two numbers in the
square brackets of what we've what we've
run
um
and how cuda ensures that the num the
order of input array is preserved in
output array
well when we execute these functions
they're going to get unique indexes
right from you know record that 30
million times so each one is going to
get from zero to 299 million 999
and each one is going to operate you
know if you're thread six you're going
to grab six from the input array and
write to index six in the output array
so that the order is going to be
preserved by using the same index you
could also do things like
reverse the order in the same way that
you know that your function could write
to 30 million minus
the index and and that would like flip
the order and it wouldn't take any more
time it would just be you're kind of
deciding how you're putting stuff back
into memory
um oh the next question is how am i
generating the gpu usage plots so yeah
let me kind of jump back over here i've
had this open just to kind of show you
what's going on and we will get to this
later but um if you click on this little
gpu icon over on the left hand side
there's a few little dashboards you can
open i've got gpu utilization and gpu
memory open
you can kind of click and drag these
around like this is jupyter lab you can
kind of rearrange and scale and smash
them about however you however you like
um so yeah if you want to open those up
to see what's going on then uh please do
but we'll come on to like how that works
later but this is like one of the big
things that i've enjoyed working on at
nvidia actually is
when you write code for the gpu
how do you know whether the gpu is busy
and how much memory you're using and you
don't really have the same tools that
you would do on the cpu you can't do
like top and free and those kind of
linux operations or look at the task
manager in the same way and get the same
kind of output so we've been working on
a bunch of tooling to make it easier and
this is just with the the jupiter lab
integration
uh
oh good you found it that's good um
is there any way to evaluate how long it
would take to load the data onto the gpu
i mean you can copy it and time it all
of these things are going to be down to
how fast is your ram how fast is your
cpu what kind of pc express connection
pci express connection do you have from
your cpu to your gpu
there's a whole bunch of factors in here
so the best thing to do is just time it
and see
if i have to reuse the output for
another operation on the gpu
i can
copy the data back uh so i can pipeline
all the operations yeah exactly you can
you can pipe them from one to the other
with the using the memory like that
why do we need to copy the data back to
the host so you can see it right if the
data is sat there on your gpu
i probably want to look at it i probably
want to use it in the input to some
other function i probably want to do
something you know if there are other
functions on the gpu we'll leave it
there for other functions on the cpu
we'll copy it back if i want to
eventually do something like
you know uh
say this is happening as part of like a
web server request somebody's uploaded
an image and you're you're writing some
code that's going to detect whether
there's a cat in the image you want to
copy the cat you want to copy the photo
to the gpu
ask if there's a cat it gives you like a
one or a zero the output array is tiny
right is it a cat is it not a cat and
then you're gonna need to answer that
http call so you're gonna have to copy
that answer back to the cpu and then
pass it to tornado or you know
whatever um to hand that back to the
user so you know
you're used to working with stuff in cpu
land you probably want to copy stuff
back to the cpu land
can the copy to host method be used
directly to instantiate an array on the
gpu or do i need to first create an
empty array that's a great question
there are tools within number for
creating arrays directly on the gpu you
can also use coupon to create arrays
directly on the gpu
so no you don't you don't actually have
to cut like create the empty array like
this
i just thought this was like an easier
narrative to explain what's going on
any book recommendations to learn more
um
it's a good question i honestly don't
know um check out the rapids blog we
blog about a lot of this stuff um we put
a lot of it on developer.nvidia.com as
well um we started moving stuff there um
i'm actually in the process of writing
up a blog post series that is this
tutorial as a blog post series that
we're putting on on developer.video.com
um
i think if you
find me on slack where i like said hello
in the hello my name is room i like
linked to my nvidia blog profile on
there
um but yeah no i don't have any books
actually maybe we should write one
uh do we need to copy to host our
resultant data so for instance plot it
using matplotlib exactly exactly that's
a great example of you know if i want to
calculate something um pulling it back
to matplotlib you've like pre-empted one
of the next notebooks because we're
going to do stuff with matplotlib and
everything um
but yes matplotlib is a cpu-based
plotting library so we need to copy the
data back to the host in order for
matplotlib to plot it we do have other
tools right if you've used data shader
before data shader has like a gpu
plotting back end um
but yeah that's that's one of the
reasons why you would copy that one
so
it's been seven minutes hopefully you're
kind of getting on well with this uh
example we're gonna move on to the
answers
uh very shortly i'm aware like this is
this tutorial is like packed full of
stuff um these questions are great it's
kind of helping me
set the pace um i don't know whether
we'll get up to the like more higher
level stuff i think it's maybe good to
stick around this this low level um but
all these materials are available
they're all on github you can keep using
them i am going to have to shut down
this binder at the end of the tutorial
um i'm afraid because it's you know
eating up my gpu budget on the cloud but
um
yeah you feel free to play with this
stuff you can you can run this notebook
on any kind of linux machine um
how would okay another question how
would we work with lazy data reading
with the gpu slash cuda do you mean lazy
data reading as in
um
data that's you might read part of the
file or something to get the headers and
then read chunks of it later yeah i mean
that's going to be like a slightly
higher level thing um
and so these calls where we're copying
stuff to the gpu is probably going to
get wrapped up in that now i know that's
a like a slightly fuzzy answer but
say uh you're doing some work like i so
i work a lot with desk right i work on
desk and we do a whole bunch of lazy
stuff in there so if you're reading csv
files or something lazily um
uh yeah coach should we use them to
press some queue or daf like das das
will handle some of this for you in the
the the higher level library the cpu
will probably peak in the file right if
you're doing like to lazily load you
need to peek in the file and then you
need to load the data out of the file
when you actually want it so in this say
in this case the cpu would probably peak
in the file to construct the like dummy
object and then when you actually need
it
it would hand off to another library to
actually do the loading and reading
with this is like an active area that
we're looking at at the moment
a lot of this stuff is kind of shaken
out for tabular data so csv parquet
but for array type data we're still
working on um
newer features there's um there's like
an upcoming thing called gds as well
which you might hear about some of the
gaming releases but it's also available
in
uh
you know the kind of work we're doing
here in computation where if you have an
nvme hard drive so plugged into a pci
slot or plugged into like an nvme slot
which is pci really on on the
motherboard the gpu can read directly
from disk to gpu memory without having
to go up through the cpu um like that
hardware is is getting there the
software is like we're still in the
middle of working on it right but what i
what i want to get to i was literally
doing some stuff yesterday where we're
trying to read from
hard drive straight onto the gpu to do
some some computation that was with some
like weather and climate data
anyway right that's great thanks for the
questions i'm going to carry on like
chugging through this material for a bit
please do throw more questions in i'll
probably pause again in a minute and go
back through
i hope that's kind of working okay for
everyone so let's go through the answers
to this lab and see uh see how you did
you can compare
so
this challenge was to implement fizzbuzz
you know standard whiteboard programming
question
but do it on the gpu for all numbers
between 1 and 50 million so let's import
our dependencies first
um just make sure and i'm going to try
and tidy up my notebooks just because i
don't run out of gpu memory or anything
silly like that so the first thing i'm
going to do is make a big array of 50
million numbers
um because that's what we're going to do
we want all the numbers from 1 to 50
million so let's use mp.a range to
create all the numbers from 1 to 50
million and then let's create an output
array
that'll be the same shape and size
now we need to calculate how many
threads and blocks we need let's just
use the chunk of code from the last one
so
128 is is a good number we'll use that
and we'll calculate how many blocks we
need
so we can you know we can just have a
look as well if
we like how many blocks do we actually
need
if that blocks 128 we need 390 000
blocks to work our way all the way over
this array great
so
the next thing we need to do is write
our kernel now there's
um
some
slightly frustrating features about
running stuff on the gpu with with
number and that's the string support on
the gpu typically hasn't isn't as mature
as as integer or float support
so instead of having number number
number fears buzz number etc um they all
need to be numbers right our numpy array
is just going to be full of numbers we
can't mix types here i tried to give a
tip to head people off from going down
the wrong path here but what we're going
to do is
instead of
having
our output array b
you know numbered number phase number
whatever we're gonna have our output
array just be like
zero if it's
not one of those one if it's fizz two if
it's buzz and three if it's fizzbuzz and
then we can use our input and output
arrays to kind of overlay that and
convert back if we want to
um so
we'll call our function it'll get input
and output
we'll get the index for where you are in
the array uh in the in the grid
we'll grab the number out of the array
we'll do some if statements with some
modulos to work out how my fears are my
buzz or my fizz buzz and we'll update
our output array only if you are one of
those things with with the correct
number so if you're not one of those
things you you just stay as a zero
so we can define that
and then if we run our
data on the gpu
that was big you know my gpu flashed all
the way up to red then on my little
utilization bar um
and so if we look at the first you know
12 items from our from our fizzbuzz we
can see it was one two fizz buzz
five fizz etc etc right and and you can
see it's calculated all that for us and
it took half a second on 50 million
numbers which is which is
uh fantastic
now uh the extra credit question here
was to calculate the highest instance of
fizz
um we can use mp.where here to work out
uh we can do mp.where output is one so
output is fizz
and then grab the zeroth element and
which is just a result of mp.ware for
some reason gives you a tuple of one
item so we'll grab that and then we'll
just do minus one to get the highest
index
and so that's given us the index of the
highest instance of fizz not the highest
and the fits so we need to just select
our index from data so we can see our
highest instance of fizz is 49 million
999 998
so
hopefully uh some of you are able to get
through that um
and work through that challenge so let's
move on to
what i think are the kind of more
compelling examples of what you can
actually do with this stuff
um i think what i'm going to do given
that we've got half an hour left um
i'm going to aim to get through
this notebook
and probably hopefully up to the lab
for this section and then we'll stop
maybe a section three talk a little bit
about how the dashboard is working um
and then can leave the koopa kudo kudif
rapids type stuff you to dig into in
your own time if you if that's of
interest to you
so let me just stop my other kernel as
well
so we've been playing with numbers so
far that's all we've been doing is just
kind of prodding around uh with numbers
and let's do something a bit more
interesting than that so gpus are very
good at video rendering and games and
all that kind of stuff so let's do some
image
manipulation with our gpu because it's
very good at working with things that
are in grids and images are in grids
so that's important stuff let's import
matplotlib we're going to use that for
looking at our images let's grab numpy
and cuda and all those kind of things
again and just configure map with the
size
now the first thing we're going to do is
i've got a nice image that we want to
look at
uh so i'm going to read it in with
matplotlib this is actually going to
create as a numpy array
of our image which is just really
helpful things we're working in in numpy
arrays already um
so it's opened this png file it's just a
regular png file that i've found on the
instead of the number logo
and i'm going to use matplotlib to read
it in as a numpy array now i can use
matplotlib to also render it for us to
plot it so if i call plot.show we can
see the number logo
so i have this array which has these
pixel values
um
of kind of all the colors and everything
in the in this array now let's copy it
onto the gpu so that we can do some work
with it so let's call um
kudo.2 device on our image and then
we're also going to grab like an output
image because we're going to we're going
to do something to this image we're
going to manipulate it so we need like
an empty image
to to manipulate into so let's make
those two things on the gpu
make sure my gpu memory fill a little
bit there as the arrays copied down
but now this is where we need to start
thinking about multi-dimensional
indexing because it's going to make our
life a lot easier
so every time we've called cuda.grid so
far we've passed it the number one to
say i want a one-dimensional index but
our image here is two dimensions right
you can see
it's 100 and something pixels by 400 and
something pixels
so it would be really handy instead of
giving us you know we're going to want
to operate on each of these pixels but
instead of giving us like you know index
732 which is probably you know in the
second row about here
it'd be great if it could just give us
like an x and y position
as our index because it is like an x and
y thing
so we can we can do exactly that we can
specify
our
threads and our blocks in multiple
dimensions and then we can ask for our
index in multiple dimensions so we're
kind of instead of
if you think about the the function
calls that we've done before we've said
i'm going to run this function 50
million times you can imagine each one
of those functions like lined up in a
row you've got 50 million it's gone off
over there
whereas
in this case what we want to do is we
want to kind of line them up in a in a
square or each one each thread is going
to represent the pixel in our image
now actually our image is made up of
multiple channels right we've got red
green and blue and we've got alpha as
well the the transparency
so we want a three-dimensional image a
three-dimensional grid to represent our
kind of technically three-dimensional
image it's a three-dimensional array
anyway
we can check that by looking at the
shape of our numpy array and it tells us
oh it's 116 high
434 pixels wide and then there are four
it's four deep and that just means
there's four channels red green blue
alpha
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to specify our our thread size
and again the same rule applies right we
want 128 threads we don't want to change
that because it's a good default
so
but we need to specify three numbers
because we want this to be a
three-dimensional index so let's just
specify three numbers that multiply
together to make 128.
um now i chose this like
semi-arbitrarily
in the
i chose four for the last number because
it's four deep so we're not actually
going to be like blocking over the the
depth the you know the channel depth of
the image um
each block is going to cover the full
like depth of the image if that makes
sense
and then i've just tried to make the
ratio you know the height and the width
ratio roughly similar to the height and
width ratio of the image but that was
just a
a choice
but now
our calculation for how many blocks we
need gets a little bit more complicated
because we need to work out well how
many blocks do we need vertically how
many blocks we need horizontally and how
many blocks do we need deep we already
know that we only need one block deep
but let's still calculate it anyway just
for
completeness
so we do our three calculations to work
out how many blocks we need and then it
will give us like a three tuple
of our shape of our blocks as well
so if i run these
i'll get my configuration settings for
our
um
our shape and if we if we multiply these
together i've got a little less
comprehension here that just multiplies
these things together it shows us that
our grid of
executions of our function is going to
be 116
high which is the same as our image
it's going to be 448 wide which is wider
than our image and it's going to be four
deep which is the same as our image so
we need to be mindful of the fact that
we're going to run more functions that
we need but it's just because we're
working in these round numbers of the of
the gpu
but let's you know let's worry about
that as we write our kernel so we're
going to write a kernel to apply uh
gaussian blur to our image
so we're gonna check each pixel and
we're gonna blur it and the way that
we're gonna blur it is we're gonna look
at a pixel and then we're gonna look at
all the pixels
directly adjacent to it and we're gonna
average them and then we're gonna update
that pixel's position in the new image
with the average of the little cluster
um
so the way we'll do this is we first
need our indexes so let's have x y and c
to represent x position y position and
channel
and we say cuda dot grid three can you
please give me a three dimensional index
and because we've specified a three
dimensional grid and block size uh we'll
get back
the right uh indices here
but just bear in mind that x uh
i think i've actually named these right
i should be because i remember um
bear in mind that we are going to go off
the edge of the image so the next thing
we do is have this if statement that
says
if you if your
indexes that you've been given by the
grid
are within
the actual shape of the image within the
bounds of the image then can you know do
this thing
and then there's no else and then the
function finishes so all of those extra
threads
uh that are kind of hanging over the
edge of the image if you like uh they're
just gonna not do anything it's gonna be
a no-op basically
so all of those that are within the
image they're gonna update the output
pixel in the output array
with the average of all of those
surrounding pixels right so we've got
our pixel in the middle xyz and then you
know i've just kind of got a little
little grid of offsets here i've tried
to arrange the code in the layout of the
thing to make it a little bit more
visual but you can see we're just going
to add all of those together then we'll
divide by nine that will give us the
average of the pixel
so if we
call that to create our function
we can now run our kernel now this isn't
like a very intense blur at all so what
i'm going to do is i'm actually going to
run the blur a few times to make it
blurrier
so i'm going to do a regular old python
4i in range five to do five levels of
blur
and all we're gonna do is we're just
gonna call our kernel five times
so
that's great in that we copied our data
to the gpu and now we're going to call
our kernel five times we're not going to
pay the memory copy penalty or anything
like that so we'll get some nice kind of
copying around going on
um
we're going to avoid the copying around
and then
but the the thing we have to be mindful
of is we've got our input image and
we're going to copy all the pixels into
our output image
and then we need to
swap them right the blur
like we we're going to need to copy to
somewhere so we need to swap them over
so our blur our blurry one ends up over
here and it's going to copy all of its
pixels into our new output array which
actually is the original input array but
it doesn't matter we're just going to
overwrite it completely but we're just
going to flip those pointers each time
we can do that in python it's very
inexpensive operation
um so
we've moved our data to the gpu we're
gonna blur it flip the pointers blur it
again flip the pointers
etc etc
so if i do that
that i didn't even put a time on the
cell but that ran very very quickly
we ran over the whole image and we ran
this blur
and now
if i want to actually have a look at my
blood my blood image is still on the gpu
right now okay so if i want to actually
look at my blurry image i need to copy
it back to the cpu and then hand it to
matplotlib for plotting so we can do
that all in one go right we can do gpu
output copy to host and then call
plot.mshow on there and if we do that we
have a blurry number logo
great
so
that's great
we've actually done some kind of useful
processing on like an array of data and
i hope this example is like a tangible
thing but then you can you know we've
done this to an image you could apply
this to video you could apply this to
gridded weather forecast data you could
apply this to you know the output of
like an mri scan or you know whatever
gridded data you're working with you can
do this kind of thing you can apply it
to tables of data you can work with all
sorts of things
you just get that kind of performance
benefit of doing big chunked parallel
operations
so the next thing uh here is another lab
let me have a look at the time we are
nearly 10 past let's this lab is pretty
similar so let's do five minutes for the
lab um and then i'll kind of go over
um the lab and talk a bit about
inspecting what your gpu is doing and
we'll wrap up a bit
so please head to the lab start working
your way through that
um
i'm just gonna have a quick drink and
then i'll go over to the chat and answer
any questions that have popped up over
there
okay no not a huge amount of questions
right so since cuda is c plus plus based
can we work with custom classes in jet
or solely work with with numpy nd arrays
so
yes and no uh
number can only compile things that it
is like aware of um so i think if you
you can make things which are based on
python primitives but um if you get too
far away from that you'll start running
into issues i mean we've
we've already kind of experienced that
we've had to work around strings because
strings aren't like super well supported
so you are going to run into some
challenges there it's best to work with
as lower level python primitives as
possible or work with uh
numpy arrays or work with the number
array which we will
actually maybe try and make time for in
a second um
so yeah let's have a look um
another question can you use the plus
equals um i
i think so i don't i
i see why not i think i was just writing
out the wrong way to be
explicit
um
and then another question isn't the last
output gpu
in
at this point just to be sure that's oh
that is a really good question actually
no it's not
because each time the name changes right
so we're swapping the pointers but every
time
we flip them
and then
oh yeah no you're absolutely right my my
apologies
you're absolutely right if i run this it
should be blurrier
than the other one yes thank you that's
it was a good spot yes because you've
done it five times i might just change
that to six times and save the notebook
uh just for the next time i run this to
make a little clearer about what's going
on but oh no that will still do it
because we're still flipping the pointer
um
yes all right i'll have to think about
that but yeah you're absolutely right
thanks for pointing that out
okay right let's
pop open this solution then we'll run
through so this is very similar to the
one that we just went through
we start with our imports
we're going to read our same image in
again
with matplotlib
let's have a quick look at it
copy it down onto the gpu
we will work out our our grid size now
we've gone from a three-dimensional need
because we're blurring we're blowing
across all the dimensions um
no we're blurring each channel in each
dimension whereas what we want to do in
this one is we want to make our image
black and white or grayscale
and so
what we're going to do actually is just
operate on a two-dimensional image i
know we've got our four deep but each
thread is going to need to access all
four of those channels because we want
to average the the rgb
right to make them all the same number
and therefore gray
so instead of specifying a
three-dimensional
grid with you know three-dimensional
blocks with three you know and a
three-dimensional grid um
we're going to specify two dimensions so
we're still going 128
threads so we'll do 16 by 16. we need to
calculate the x and y
and we'll set up our blog block shape as
well
now our kernel
uh again looks very similar but we're
going to grab a two-dimensional grid so
we'll get x and y with a good grid of
you know two two dimensions
we'll make sure that our uh
thread is actually inside the image
and then in here we're going to
calculate the average of each pixel
across the channels right so we want to
average r g and b
and then we want to update
each of our g and b
with that average
um and then we just want to pass the
alpha channel straight through right if
there's transparency it should still be
transparent if it's not transparent it
should still not be transparent
so we'll just pass that number straight
through so we end up updating our output
array
and then we can run the same kind of
call right again remember we have our
function call with square brackets to
configure it how big it should be
and then our inputs so if we run that
runs on the gpu and we can have a look
we have grayscout our image
so
in this first half of this tutorial like
this you know this is a longer tutorial
that we put in this 90 minute slot but
in this first first chunk of this
tutorial we've really gone through
about as low level as you can go in
python working on the gpu we've written
functions we've executed those functions
we've moved memory around we've done all
that kind of stuff
but you know we've been helped
throughout by these little plots on the
side showing us how busy the gpu is and
how much memory we're using and things
and that's all been thanks to
this library that we have which
interacts with the nvidia driver called
nvml uh you can see we've got this this
is a screenshot from
the github page for this jupyter lab
extension you can see this is from a
machine with eight gpus and it's a
server
and you can see all the kind of gpus
bouncing around how much memory we're
using uh we're using das to record this
as well um
and so
uh this all of this is using nvml to
query the gpu and say
how busy are you how much memory you're
using etc and we can do that ourselves
if we want to kind of get into what the
gpu is doing so
we can import pi nvml this package all
of these packages by the way i didn't
really mention this is all in this
binder environment uh the docker file is
here this is just based on the rapids
container right which has just got all
of the tools in that that we work with
but you can also install all this stuff
mostly with conda um due to their like
complex dependencies
dependencies so if we import pi and vml
we first have to call nvml init which
just tells the library to connect to the
gpu but then we can do things like get
the device get count it says okay in my
cluster at the moment i've got one gpu
on my workstation that i have for work i
have two gpus on the server i might have
eight it'll tell me how many i have
i can also get the driver version tells
me this is driver version 450.
um
and then i can also i i can ask specific
things about each gpu so you know we've
only got one so it's not a huge thing
but um we have to first get a handle
um for our gpu this is kind of like a
pointer to something we can ask about
the gpu so uh we're gonna get the number
of gpus we're gonna
do four i in range you know how many
gpus we have
and grab a handle for that gpu so i mean
this is just going to give me a list of
one
1.1 handle
but as i said on other machines it would
give you more
and
we can then do things like
get device name for our gpu for gpu and
gpus right we can go through all of our
our one gpus um and get the name so this
is a tesla p100 pci express 16 gig model
this is you know just the one that i
picked in in google cloud for my
kubernetes cluster um
and i can do things like how much uh get
memory info and then have a look at how
much memory is being used it is you know
half a gig which kind of lines up with
uh my my plot over here
and then i can
say how much is free and it's like well
this is a 16 gig gpu so this is uh you
know it actually works out to like 17 or
so with
rounding but um
yeah this is how we can query these
things you can dig into this library
these are just direct bindings the c
library so you have to dig through the
nvidia docs um
but yeah this is this is kind of how
these tools work how you can integrate
with with other tooling if that's
something that you you work on or
interested in um but i just kind of
wanted to share this there's this
extension called uh jupiter lab mv
dashboard which integrates with jupiter
it has also got like a standalone
dashboard that you can look at these
things
um these are just like iframes in here
so i guess you could open uh these
frames in new tabs as well and
just have a look at these plots
individually
so as well as being able to query what's
going on in your gpu
oh let me come back up here
let me just spend the last 10 minutes
very quickly going through what else is
in this tutorial please do feel free to
you know save these notebooks and and
have a look through them in your own
time and also keep an eye out for the
blog post series that i'm working on
that is the full extent of this tutorial
um
but
we have within the rapid suite of tools
coopers was actually born out of the the
chain of project right that we've kind
of uh we helped maintain it as part of
rapids as well
um
is is kind of like a direct replacement
for numpy
that follows exactly the same api
but everything runs on the gpu so you
can kind of forget everything that i've
just told you about threads and blocks
and warps and
kernels and all that kind of stuff
because if you use numpy and you want it
to go faster on the gpu you can just
swap and use coupon instead
um so
uh
yeah i'm gonna spend a few minutes let's
just have a quick look through this i'll
skip the lab i guess but um if i import
numpy and if i import coupe i
um i can make a cpu array and i can also
make a gpu array
these are just empty arrays full of ones
and
it's i mean it's very fast to make an
empty array of ones directly on the gpu
i think one of the questions in the chat
was about can you make arrays directly
on the gpu yes you can coupey is a great
tool for allowing you to do that um no
i'm having to call this synchronized
call here just because um some coupe i
calls are like async they run in a
thread in the background and so if i
timed just this it wouldn't have been
true so the synchronize is just making
us wait for that to actually finish
we can see it's nice and fast to make
into arrays on the gpu
we can do basic operations right we can
you know multiply all the numbers in in
the array by five and that is nice and
fast on the gpu
we can
do
kind of more fancy multiplications that
take longer and kind of see while this
is running
20 times faster on the gpu to do these
multiplications
and we can also do kind of more complex
operations we could do like a you know
singular vector
singular value decomposition from the
linear algebra package
and again running that on the cpu will
take a few seconds uh running on the gpu
this was being strange for me before
actually oh there we go i was talking
about three about times run again yeah
okay
something happens with initializing my
gpu sometimes um but you see this takes
a lot less time to run on the gpu than
on the cpu
so
yeah let's um
yeah this this last example here is just
showing that
one of the nice features about numpy is
if you ask numpy to do something to an
array that's not a numpy array but is
numpy like
numpy will dispatch to the correct
library so you can see
we create our gpu array here with coupei
but then we're going to call
numpy.linear algebra.svd
and pass our gpu array and when we
execute this function numpy will look at
this and say well that's not a numpy
array you should have called
coupy.algebra svd and it just calls that
for you so actually if you want to swap
a numpy workload to being a cooper by
workload a lot of it is just changing
the way that you create the data you
just import coupon and create your data
nothing else in your codebase has to
really change um and that will run run
the same
so there's a lab here let's skip over
that um
the last little thing i think that is
probably worth mentioning
uh about coupe i
is
all of these tools you know we've talked
about number we've talked about kind of
low level c plus plus stuff we've talked
about
occupy all of these are raised there's a
cost of copying them around and
transforming them and stuff so one of
the things that we have that we we build
as part of rapids is something called
the cuda array interface and this is an
interface that allows us to just convert
one array type to another
um but we leave the data alone right if
we've got a big array of numbers on the
gpu
that's a couple array we can convert
that coupon array
into like a number device array
just by kind of swapping some pointers
around and smashing some metadata about
a bit um
so that but but with leaving all the
number the data alone because they're
just it's just a you know
c plus array on the gpu at the end of
the day all of these things have the
same kind of primitive
memory
representation um it's just they're like
decorator on top i guess and that the
way it's exposed into python and so um
just to quickly show that we can convert
from one to the other really easily
if we create a big coupe array
and have a look at it
um
oh my i've just run out of memory no
okay that's fine if we have a look at my
big coupe array it's big it's bigger
than you know half my memory i think
um so i can't copy it in memory because
it's taking up a lot of ram but i can
convert it to to a coupon a number
array
just by doing two device on this and
it's not copied it's just giving me a
new array
and then i can do coupe i don't as array
to convert it back again and we just
kind of smoosh the pointer around
something to think about it a little bit
to construct coupons representation um i
think it also copied it back to the cpu
just so we can see it again
but we can do this
very easily and a lot of libraries
support this so if you've got data in
pytorch if you've got data occupy you
can kind of convert from one to the
other type
in a really straightforward way which is
something that was uh hassle for a long
time
so the last two parts of this which i'm
not going to go through is we have a
library called qdf which is exactly like
pandas um
but for
on you know gpu accelerated computing so
if you work with tabular data if you
work with pandas have a look at qdf uh
is it feels the same it looks the same
the api is the same
um it's just on the gpu
and then we also have qml which is like
scikit-learn so there's a nice example
here if you do want to run through it
which loads in some uh a data set on on
some people and whether or not they have
diabetes and then uh trains a model to
predict based on inputs like blood
pressure and glucose levels and things
whether or not that person has diabetes
um
and it does all the same kind of stuff
it uses qdf and it uses qml to load the
data in from a csv file to the gpu
trainer model on it and do some
predictions
so
that's kind of it we're like roughly
up to time
um
i'm going to yeah we're going to save
three minutes uh questions well we have
to give up the room so
if there's any last questions that jacob
could fit in just quickly there and
otherwise if you could take it up with
him on slack that would be amazing
yeah exactly let me just have a quick
look through the the chat um
uh somebody asked did the threads per
block multiply 256 possibly that might
have just been a bug but 256 is still
fine uh can someone share the repo for
the number lab notebooks yes they are
i'll share it here again so it's on
github it's jacob tomlinson
uh i'll put this in the chat right
that's probably the most sensible thing
to do
so you can definitely go and find those
notebooks
uh yep oh somebody else has to put that
inside i should read ahead a little bit
uh how can someone create and work with
temporary gpu arrays within a jit
function
um
generally you can't right within a jit
function you can't create new memory you
can only work with what you've been
given so you have to think about that
ahead of time
uh
next question does coupon integrate with
other packages the same way numpy does
yes it does it follows the same api so
things should just should just work
uh is there any advantage of using numpy
plus number cuda instead of coupe i if
you want to get deeper and more gritty
with the kind of functions you're
writing then yes if you really have
something um
where you know we've done this kind of
stuff with image manipulation where
we've written a custom kernel that
calculates um a blur on an image that
might there might just not be a standard
function like that in coupon for doing
whatever you're trying to do so um yeah
if something is built into coupe i great
go and use it if you really need to get
into the weeds then use use number and
as i said you can swap the arrays back
and forth at any point to do that we do
it a bunch in rapids for the higher
level libraries
um but yeah that's it's 29 minutes past
we have to give up the room thank you so
much for coming thank you all for kind
of sticking around and we've got a good
kind of solid number all the way through
so i really appreciate your attention if
you've got any questions please feel
free to ping me on slack
or on twitter
and see you all around
and thank you very much jacob it was
really informative very detailed and
incredibly organized so
sure thanks all for joining bye now